[Musica]
io mi fido di te è una frase bellissima
va dire una persona perché presuppone il
fatto che affideremo a questa persona i
nostri beni più cari e più preziose
affideremo a questa persona la capacità
di decidere al posto nostro
essendo sicuri che le decisioni prese
sarebbero prese per il nostro bene a
nostro beneficio voi direste mai io mi
fido di te ad una macchina ad un robot o
un computer per quanto intelligente
possa essere lì affidereste i vostri
beni più preziosi i vostri dati
personali tranquillamente non lascereste
prendere decisioni al posto vostro
essendo sicuri che queste decisioni
vengano prese per il vostro bene
beh oggi proviamo a rispondere ad una
domanda e la domanda è se noi siamo in
grado di far entrare nel cerchio della
nostra fiducia oltre che agli umani
anche delle macchine e vogliamo anche
rispondere alla domanda se è possibile
che queste tecniche di intelligenza
artificiale di cui abbiamo sentito
parlare oggi in effetti possano essere
usate per il nostro bene a beneficio
nostro a beneficio della società e
dell'ambiente in cui viviamo
mi occupo di intelligenza artificiale da
più di vent'anni come docente
ricercatrice e mi occupo dei sistemi di
supporto alle decisioni sono dei sistemi
che non si sostituiscono all'uomo ma che
lo supportano lo aiutano a prendere
decisioni informate propongono scenari
alternativi valutano costi e tipicamente
cercano di minimizzarli valutano impatti
questi sistemi e devono in qualche modo
esibire una qualche forma di
intelligenza perché devono ragionare
devono imparare devono elaborare una
grande quantità di dati tipicamente e
devono anche adattarsi alle situazioni
devono veramente mostrare una qualche
forma di intelligenza la cosiddetta
intelligenza artificiale
ultimamente sentiamo tanto parlare di
intelligenza artificiale sui media
social network a volte bene a volte male
ma perché c'è tutta questa attenzione
perché come abbiamo visto anche negli
interventi precedenti negli ultimi anni
ci sono stati dei risultati straordinari
straordinari che fino a qualche tempo fa
non erano assolutamente pensabile
qualche esempio la visione artificiale
fino al 2010 e sono otto anni fa e anni
fa le capacità di una persona erano
molto superiori a quelli di un computer
per fare che cosa per esempio
riconoscere quello che c'è il contenuto
di un immagine il contenuto di un video
erano molto superiore la linea rossa che
vedete alle mie spalle l sono le
performance di un essere umano
da quando qualche anno fa è stato
scoperto in queste tecniche di player
ning che hanno portato a dei grandissimi
risultati
le performance di una macchina hanno
raggiunto e addirittura superato la
capacità di un uomo nel riconoscere per
esempio il contenuto di un immagine
descriverla
un altro esempio pensiamo al question
answering maggiorana sua arringa e la
capacità di rispondere a tre domande e
trento conoscenza da per esempio quello
che troviamo sulla rete dai libri
enciclopedie in modo veloce e di qualche
anno fa è la notizia di una donna
giapponese affetta da una forma molto
rara di leucemia che è stata quindi
diciamo malattia e stata diagnosticata
la sistema di intelligenza artificiale
watson di ibm stata trovata una cura e
questo è ovviamente è un ambito in cui
l'intelligenza artificiale porta
benefici all'uomo inoltre l'intelligenza
artificiale è stata anche usata in
ambiti che sono prettamente umane la
creatività cosa sono dei dipinti che
sono stati fatti da una macchina di
intelligenza artificiale
vedrete qualche somiglianza con dipinti
reali ma questi sono dipinti originali
nella musica nella scrittura risultati
straordinari ma ne abbiamo anche paura
quando pensiamo alla intelligenza
artificiale a volte ci vengono in mente
degli scenari apocalittici in cui i
robot prendono coscienza di sé e si
combattono per avere il sopravvento
sulla razza umana siamo al termine tor
matrix ma senza andare a scomodare la
fantascienza
ci sono alcuni usi dell'intelligenza
artificiale che sono dannosi per l'uomo
si pensi alle armi autonome
per me autonome ci sono investimenti
costanti sulle armi autonomi e qui la
decisione da prendere e se togliere o
meno una vita umana e quindi c'è stata
una petizione poco tempo fa firmata da
circa 3 mila scienziati in tutto il
mondo per bandire la ricerca di
intelligenze artificiali nelle armi
autonome in uno scenario ancora più
vicino a noi
il mondo del lavoro si pensa che nel
2030 il 30 per cento dei posti di lavoro
verrà soppiantato da intelligente
artificiale da macchine e questo ci fa
paura
ovviamente perché il mondo del lavoro
cambierà alcune professioni spariranno
altri verranno radicalmente modificate
ne abbiamo paura ma di oggi vogliamo
cercare di capire un'altra cosa se
queste tecniche possono essere usati a
benefici al nostro della nostra società
del nostro ambiente vogliamo cioè vedere
se l'intelligenza artificiale può essere
usato nel campo della sostenibilità
dello sviluppo sostenibile è uno
sviluppo e le nostre generazioni che non
inficia lo sviluppo delle generazioni
future
e in questi ambiti problemi decisionali
sono veramente complesse
provate a pensare alla gestione di un
ecosistema apprestava a preservare un
ecosistema che decisioni dobbiamo
prendere che cosa dobbiamo investire ma
pensiamo per esempio anche a quelli che
si chiamano sistemi socio tecnici
sistemi cioè in cui convivono delle
infrastrutture costruite dall'uomo è
l'uomo stesso e la società per esempio
le smart cities le città del futuro
per esempio le smart grid cioè le reti
elettriche del futuro perché sono
complesse queste decisioni beh perché
coinvolgono tantissimi fattori
coinvolgono infrastrutture costruite
dall'uomo coinvolgono l'ambiente
coinvolgono fattori economici
il fattore umano dinamiche sociali
e prendere decisioni in questi ambiti è
veramente complicato l'intelligenza
artificiale ci può dare una mano
costruendo modelle modelli sono
approssimazioni della realtà ma sono
utili per aiutarci a prendere decisioni
e i modelli sono di tre tipi tipicamente
modelli descrittivi che descrivono il
sistema su cui vogliamo decidere
descrivono le sue componenti e
interazioni tra questi componenti
modelli predittivi cioè che cercano di
prevedere quella che è la dinamica
futura di un sistema e modelli
decisionali o prescrittivi che sono
appunto quelli che ci aiutano a prendere
decisioni e farò un esempio questo
esempio è un esempio nella in un
problema di gestione di calamità
naturali ed è un sistema che è stato
sviluppato al nigth in australia da un
gruppo capitanato dal professore la
tuscan valente rick ed è la gestione di
una diva con una coazione di un più di
un intero parti popolazione in seguito
all'esondazione di una diga la diga si
chiama diga di huayra gamba sta nella
auguri nepal region e ogni tanto esorta
coprendo una superficie che coinvolge
70.000 persone in 50 zone residenziali
che devono essere portate in salvo prima
dell'arrivo dell'acqua e possibilmente
con i loro mezzi
c'è una rete stradale chiaramente per
fare questo e ci sono dei dati storici
per analizzare i fenomeni che sono
successi nel passato
e allora abbiamo i nostri modelli che ci
danno una mano
i modelli descrittivi che descrivono la
rete stradale
i flussi di traffico che questa rete
riesce a sostenere a supportare abbiamo
la densità di popolazione abbiamo un
sacco di dati e con questi dati possiamo
estrarre modelli descrittivi poi abbiamo
i modelli predittivi e questa è una
simulazione dell'arrivo dell'acqua e
questa simulazione la simulazione che
il modello simulativa modello matematico
molto complesso ma ci dice esattamente
con grande accuratezza quando arriverà
l'acqua in una certa zona e quando una
strada verrà interrotta dall'arrivo
dell'acqua sulla base di questo modello
previsionale predittivo noi vogliamo
costruire dei piani di evacuazione
in questo video noi vediamo due piani al
confronto questo il primo è quello della
protezione civile quello diciamo
costruito da esseri umani che cerca di
portare in salvo le persone prima
dell'arrivo dell'acqua e prende
determinate decisioni vedete questi
blocchetti ni verdi sono insiemi di
macchine gruppi di macchine però ahimè
11.000 delle 73 mila persone coinvolte
rimangono intrappolate in zone allagate
e quindi dovranno essere portati in
salvo in modi diversi
queste sono diciamo degli zoom su questo
piano in cui appunto l'acqua arrivare
queste persone non riescono ad andarsene
con i propri mezzi e capita diciamo su
11 mila persone quindi queste decisioni
sono state prese da esseri umani molto
esperti a dir la verità questo invece è
un piano la simulazione di un piano
d'evacuazione suggerito da un sistema
decisionale basato su la predizione
dell'arrivo dell'acqua che vedete arriva
da dan orta dal dall'alto e riesce a
portare in salvo tutte quante le persone
ma vedete fa bene cosa è un po strane
perché in basso a sinistra fa partire
delle macchine anche se sono molto
lontane dall arrivo dell'acqua perché sa
che se non lo facesse queste
rimarrebbero intrappolate quando l'acqua
arriva bello adesso la domanda però è ma
le persone si comportano davvero come
noi gli diciamo di comportarsi
e la risposta è ovviamente no
c'è il fattore umano da tenere in
considerazione le persone in certe
situazioni si lasciano prendere dal
panico agiscono in modo irrazionale
vogliono proteggere i propri cari e
possono agire in modo egoistico e allora
che cosa dobbiamo fare li faccio un
esempio se noi vogliamo liberare una
certa zona e facciamo evacuare le
persone in due momenti diversi della
giornata e prima la mattina il secondo
pomeriggio quelle che restano che vedono
alcuni che partono tipicamente si fanno
prendere dal panico e partono anche loro
creando degli ingorghi che non si
verificherebbero se partissero quando
glielo dice diciamo il il piano
costruito la sistema decisionale ma
questo è abbastanza normale
e allora che fare beh questo fattore
umano deve essere inserito all'interno
dei modelli e quindi modellare anche il
fattore umano oltre che la rete stradale
l'arrivo dell'acqua noi dobbiamo
modellare il fatto che abbiamo a che
fare con delle persone che agiscono in
modo irrazionale e poi la domanda più
difficile
supponiamo che è proprio questo piano di
evacuazione che porta in salvo tutti non
esista chi lasciateli un sistema di
intelligenza artificiale può deciderlo
e allora deve in qualche modo metter su
una bilancia le vite umane
chi lascia che ti porta in salvo e
questi sono è un fattore etico d'accordo
noi vorremmo che quelle decisioni
fossero prese da un sistema in modo non
discriminante in modo trasparente in
modo equo rispettando i nostri diritti
la nostra privacy
beh se lo chiedete a me io prima di
tutto porterei in salvo i bambini forse
alcuni di voi saranno anche d'accordo
con me però se voi guardate c'è un
esperimento interessantissimo che si
chiama the moral machine fatto d'alema e
te che partendo dall esperimento sulla
guida autonoma in realtà riesce a
partizionare il nostro il mondo
in cinque zone diverse che hanno
principi etici e morali completamente
diversi
cioè se voi chiedete a una persona che
vive in cina non sud est asiatico si
salvare prima un bambino o no
probabilmente non salverebbe prima un
bambino ma una persona anziana perché la
persona anziana detiene la saggezza e
quindi non salverebbero probabilmente
prima un bambino ma allora non esistono
principi etici universali e quindi come
facciamo a modellare questi principi
etici come facciamo a metterli nei
nostri modelli decisionali ed è proprio
su questo che la ricerca si deve
concentrare il sistema di intelligenza
artificiale stanno diventando sempre più
potenti sempre più pervasivi e come
diceva lo zio di peter parker nonché
spider man è un grande potere deriva una
grande responsabilità quindi noi
vogliamo in ultima analisi che i sistemi
di intelligenza artificiale che
decideranno per noi che decidono per noi
agiscano in modo responsabile
aderendo ai nostri principi etici e
morali
chiaramente per far questo la strada è
lunga e ci sono sicuramente due punti in
cui con su cui concentrarsi una e la
ricerca
cioè noi oltre alla ricerca sui fattori
tecnici metodologici e scientifici
dobbiamo anche concentrarci su come
inserire fattori umani ed etici e morali
all'interno dei modelli ed inoltre nevi
amante la responsabilità di educare
delle persone sempre su questi fattori
anche sull'etica perché vogliamo che i
sistemi decisionali anche in futuro
siano dei sistemi che agiscono
responsabilmente per cui io possa dire
io mi fido di te grazie
[Applauso]